Trascrizione: Sara Lobasso
Revisore: Simona Donda
“Quanto tempo ho?”
Se avessimo posto
questa domanda ad Aristotele,
probabilmente anzi, certamente
ci avrebbe attaccato un pippone
sulla questione cosmica,
il moto dei pianeti e chissà cos’altro.
L’altro giorno,
preparandomi a questo discorso,
sono andato su Google e ho cercato
“Come sfruttare al meglio il tuo tempo?”
E, mi sono usciti i classici
articoli da rivista.
“Come sfruttare il tuo tempo
in cinque mosse?”,
“Le otto cose da sapere”,
“I cinque consigli”.
Ma c'è veramente un metodo
per sfruttarlo al meglio?
Il tempo è una cosa relativa,
il tempo è una cosa personale,
il tempo è una cosa generazionale.
Quante volte vi è capitato
che un padre o una madre
vi dicesse di non buttare via
il tempo con il cellulare
mentre voi siete sul divano
e state organizzando la vacanza
coi vostri amici.
Questo per voi è perdere tempo?
È perdere tempo farci
i cavoli degli altri su Instagram,
o guardare i video dei gattini
su Facebook?
Per i nostri nonni, sì.
Alla nostra età loro avevano
priorità diverse, più concrete forse.
Come mettere su famiglia,
trovarsi un buon lavoro,
costruirsi la propria casa e, perché no,
comprarsi anche una bella macchina.
Noi adesso abbiamo priorità
un pochino più di facciata, forse.
Come, dove uscire al sabato sera,
non farsi fare le corna
dal moroso o dalla morosa,
farsi la vacanza al mare solo
per poi mettere le storie su Instagram.
Noi siamo i ragazzi della Generazione Z,
noi siamo i ragazzi sempre connessi,
quelli che si disinteressano di politica,
quelli sempre infelici, superficiali.
Però forse da questo nostro
essere sempre connessi,
abbiamo tratto un sacco di conoscenza,
magari in maniera involontaria.
Sempre i nostri nonni,
quando dovevano studiare un argomento
o leggere per imparare qualcosa,
dovevano mettersi lì intere sere,
interi pomeriggi con
libri, riviste, quaderni.
A noi adesso basta guardare un tutorial,
un paio di post e sentire un podcast.
La resa è la stessa?
Se potessi lasciare una grande massima
a me bambino sarebbe:
Non farti incastrare dalle definizioni.
Non lasciare che le definizioni che
gli altri ti danno siano la tua biografia.
Poi smetti di definire gli altri.
Non esistono né grandi né piccoli,
né vincitori né falliti.
Esistiamo solo noi, solo te.
Decidi sempre, ogni giorno,
chi essere veramente, di essere te stesso.
Il tempo ha la funzione di insegnarci,
la funzione anche di aggiustare il tiro.
Con il tempo le cose si risolvono.
Il tempo ha una funzione anche nel vino,
è una cosa fondamentale.
Noi come il vino cresciamo e
all’inizio siamo un po’ così,
poi col tempo magari miglioriamo.
E come un enologo fa col vino,
i professori fanno con noi,
ci fa crescere, ci fa cambiare.
Guardiamo un bicchiere,
un semplice flûte.
Quando noi versiamo dentro il vino,
tutte le bolle pian piano
arrivano fino in cima.
Ognuna con il suo tempo.
Ognuna con il suo modo.
Noi lo facciamo nella vita,
ma anche tutti i giorni.
Basta cogliere l’attimo,
basta guardare il momento.
Sfruttare pienamente il tempo nel lavoro
ci favorisce? Nella vita ci favorisce?
Ecco, forse sì.
In amore, con il tempo
abbiamo perso un po’ di cose.
Siamo passati dalla serenata sotto casa
al messaggino su WhatsApp col cuoricino.
Nel lavoro abbiamo abbiamo perso
la parte pratica forse,
ogni tanto, non in tutti i lavori.
Siamo passati dal mattone, tutti i giorni,
allo smart working.
La resa è la stessa?
La nostra società è vittima
di un grandissimo equivoco.
Confondiamo il “cogli l’attimo”
col volere tutto subito.
Però forse è il caso di fermarci
ed esercitare l’attesa.
Forse do un altro consiglio ai ragazzi che
sono qua oggi e a quelli che non ci sono.
Ogni tanto fermiamoci e
guardiamo con gli occhi dei nostri nonni.
Per vedere che cosa ne traiamo,
che punto di vista ne possiamo ottenere.
Forse sommando le cose veramente arriviamo
alla gestione perfetta del tempo.
A voi.
(Applausi)